but the point was to prevent me from  turning into a hulk these  transformations are triggered by  distressed emotional states so we need  to know the exact threshold that causes  it for you the triggers are anger and  fear  those are like the baseline of any woman  just existing all right then let's try  this  [Music]  [Applause]  bruce  i just feel like if i don't transform  i'm gonna die you haven't planned me for  that ah nope  nope you're just gonna kill me  [Music]  when you're a hulk trouble's gonna find  you this thursday weird  unexpected trouble  let's do this  seahawk culture  [Applause]  but it's not where you think  just remember whose show this actually  is she-hulk is streaming on disney plus  this thursday  you